the cpi or consumer price index is used
to measure the cost of a typical basket
of goods the typical household in the
nation of jacksonia buys four loaves of
bread three pounds of cream cheese and
eight books each week
the prices of these goods in years 2015
2016 and 2017 are given in the table
below
and then they ask us some questions
calculate the cpi in 2017 using 2016 as
the base year calculate the cpi in 2015
using 2016 as the base year calculate
the rate of inflation between 2015 and
2016. calculate the rate of inflation
between 2016 and 2017 and then describe
a reason why the inflation rate between
2016 and 2017 might overstate the
changes in cost of living so pause this
video and see if you can work through it
before i do it with you
all right now let's just do it step by
step so this first two letters they want
us to calculate the cpi's in 2017 and
2015 using 2016 as a base year so the
way i'm going to do it i'm going to set
up a new column here which is cost
of the weekly basket because and they
tell us how much they buy each week cost
of weekly
weekly
basket
let's see in 2015 they buy four loaves
of bread at a dollar each so it's going
to be four times one
plus they buy three pounds of cream
cheese at three dollars a pound plus
three times three
plus they buy eight books a week these
people like to read and so and each book
in 2015 is ten dollars so eight times
ten
8 times 10 and this is going to be equal
to 4 times 1 is 4 plus 9 is 13
plus 80 is going to be
now that same basket that weekly basket
in 2016 well we're buying four loaves of
bread at two dollars now four times two
plus we're buying three pounds of cream
cheese at six dollars a pound now plus
three times six
plus eight books per week at twenty
dollars per book eight times twenty
this is going to be equal to eight
plus eighteen which is twenty six plus a
hundred and
sixty is one hundred and eighty
so this is going to be 186
dollars and now we're going to do the
same thing in 2017.
each week you're gonna get four loaves
of bread now it's three dollars per loaf
plus we're buying three pounds of cream
cheese per week three it's still at six
dollars per pound plus eight books per
week at 25 dollars per book
and so this is going to be equal to 12
plus 18 which is 30 plus 200 which is
going to be
230 dollars
and now we can calculate the cpi's
so the cpi
it's typical that it's going to be 100
in your base year should be 100 so i
could just put that there and for the
other years you could say the basket
cost
cost in a year
divided by the cost and base year cost
in base
year year times 100. so obviously in
2016 that's going to be the cost in 2016
divided by the cost in 2016 times 100
you'll get 100. but for 2015 it will be
the cost of the basket in 2015 which is
93 dollars divided by the cost in 2016
which is 186 dollars times 100 this one
is actually pretty straightforward 93 is
half of 186 so this is going to be equal
to 50. and then in 2017 it's going to be
the cost of the basket in 2017
divided by the
cost of the basket in 2016
times 100 which is going to be equal to
i'm going to use a calculator for this
one 230
divided by
is equal to
approximately
1.24 if we multiply that times 100 we'll
say it's approximately
it is approximately
124. so calculate the cpi in 2017 using
2016 as the base year it would be 124.
calculate the cpi in 2015 using 2016 as
the base year that is 50.
calculate the rate of inflation between
2015 and 2016. so how much do prices
grow
if we take this basket of goods from
2015 to 2016.
well you could look at your cpi i went
from 50 to 100. so prices doubled and so
something's doubled you grew by a
hundred percent and the rate of
inflation is the growth in prices and so
this is 100
inflation things doubled in price and
you can see it here everything doubled
in price right over here calculate the
rate of inflation between 2016 and 2017.
well if you start at 100 and you grow to
124 you have just grown by 24
one way to think about as you multiply
by 1.24 which is the same thing as
growing by 24
so that 24 growth is the rate of
inflation
describe a reason why the inflation rate
between 2016 and 2017 so that's what we
answered right here in part d might
overstate changes in the cost of living
and if you haven't answered that part
yet i encourage you given all that we've
done try to pause the video and try to
think about that
so let's look at what happened from 2016
to 2017.
the price of a loaf of bread increases
by 50 percent the price of a book
increases by five dollars on a base of
20 that's an increase of 25 percent but
the price of cream cheese does not
change plus zero percent it experiences
no inflation from 2016 to 2017. and so
you could imagine a scenario where if
some goods their prices increase a lot
while others don't
the basket of goods might change people
might buy less bread and less and fewer
books and more cream cheese and so we
could say
the
typical
basket
might
get
more
weighted
to
goods
that
had less inflation had
less
inflation
example
in this case would be cream cheese
cream
cheese
because
they
look
relatively
cheaper
to the goods that had more inflation
and if that happened you would have a
lower
actual growth
in
cost
of
living and this last question really
alludes to the fact that the cpi isn't
necessarily a perfect indicator that as
different goods in the basket it have a
price inflation at different rates you
could have a substitution effect between
the various goods now in countries they
try to rebalance the basket of goods
based on a perception of what is typical
but once again that is not necessarily
going to be perfect